Morgen Linus.
Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim. Du warst weg. So ist es.
Du warst weg. So ist es. Und und und was was bist du jetzt?
Wieder da.
Wir sind wieder da, Logbuch Netzpolitik, die sechsundneunzigste Ausgabe nach einer längeren Durststrecke äh ohne Linus jetzt wieder mal mit Linus.
Das war gar keine Durststrecke, das war doch war ja OK, aber das war also.
Aber ich habe, habe mir eine interessante Drinks bestellt. Also ich hatte hier äh mit Herrn Lohninger da eine schöne äh netzpolitisches äh Anstoßen.
Das war so ein Kaminfeuergespräch.
Das war wirklich sehr nett so. Also ein schöner Einblick in äh Brüssel. Wir müssen ihn auch äh zeitnah mal wieder einladen, weil äh ne, kommen wir auch noch, glaube ich, äh gleich dazu.
Äh ich denke, da ist äh demnächst nochmal ein
Update von vor Ort auch fällig und ja, Dank auch noch mal an äh Peter Pixer, der das hier in der letzten Sendung auch äh bravurös äh gemeistert hat und
ja, zur allgemeinen Zufriedenheit hier deinen Vertreter gemacht hat. Dann haben wir nochmal eine Woche Pause gemacht, weil hat sich so recht nicht ergeben. Aber jetzt sind wir wieder da.
Ja und ich habe in der Zeit äh mit meiner schönen, neuen Kameraspeicherkarte Fotos gemacht und mit meinem schönen neuen Milchaufschäumer äh Kaffee,
und äh ja, Leute, wenn ihr irgendwie noch nicht mal also ich finde das gut, wenn Leute so auf Datenschutz bedacht sind so, ne? Und jetzt nicht irgendwie nur, weil ich dem irgendwie was von Amazon bestelle, musste ja nicht wissen, wer ich bin. Finde ich gut,
Aber wer wer es schafft, da irgendwie einen Rückkanal mit anzugeben, dem dem antworte ich ja dann auch gerne.
Mhm. Das hast du dann auch getan. Ging ja nicht. Ach so ging in dem Fall nicht.
Ging ja nicht. Vielleicht habe ich die auch selber beschert und gedacht und vergessen. Nein, nein.
Gut, also Mischäumen ist jetzt auf jeden Fall alles kein Problem.
Milchschwimmen kann ich.
Ist ja gut, ne, wenn dein äh Alltag jetzt so durchautomatisiert ist, ist es ja auch wieder ein bisschen Zeit für das politische Informationsleistung, ne.
Ist einfach ein manueller Milchaufschauer. Also das äh also kennst du die? Ja. Noch nicht durch. Also mein Alltag ist noch nicht ganz so durchautomatisiert.
Ja gut, aber wenn's mitm Schneebesen da arbeiten müsstest, dann würde es sicherlich länger dauern.
Das ist richtig und die Qualität des Schaumes ist auch einfach eine andere,
Nein, der hat einfach eine sehr, sehr feine Konsistenz. Kann man nicht, äh also muss man.
Okay, ne, schauen wir mal, wie die äh Qualität der Nachrichtenlage äh so ist. Ja.
Der Nachrichtenanlage, ja.
Ja. Also, wir haben hier äh in Europa gibt's jetzt äh wir haben lange drüber diskutiert. Jetzt äh ist dann auch tatsächlich mal was,
Passiert rund um die Datenschutzverordnung, die ja ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange jetzt in der Diskussion war, mindestens Ewigkeiten auf jeden Fall.
Und zwar Ewigkeiten, weil ich weiß, dass wir beim neunundzwanzig C drei hatten wir dann Kirsten
Und Jan, äh Jan-Philipp Albrecht und irgendwie noch zwei weitere Personen ähm da, die dann darüber erzählt haben. Und beim dreißig C drei ja nochmal
Da war dann aber nur der äh Jan-Philipp Albrecht und.
Also wir nicht Logbuch Netzpolitik, sondern wir, der Kongress an der Stelle, äh wo dadrüber berichtet wurde.
Wir die äh die Netzgemeinde. Ja. Und dann jetzt war ich irgendwie sehr überrascht und dann las die Überschrift, oh ja, Datenschutzverordnung passiert das Parlament. So im EU-Parlament hat darüber,
abgestimmen gestimmt und dann dachte ich, aha, krass, jetzt ist ja ähm,
Jetzt ist ja jetzt ist es endlich beschlossen, aber nein, aber nein. Denn ähm das war jetzt nur der,
Äh der der Text von Jan-Philipp Albrecht, von dem Berichterstatter, der dort in erster Lesung ähm,
mit sechshunderteinundzwanzig von sechshundertdreiundfünfzig abgegebenen Stimmen angenommen wurde. Aber im Ministerrat,
äh
herrscht er weiterhin die Verzögerungstaktik und jetzt werden wir halt sehen, also es muss halt irgendwie noch dieser Ministerrat muss jetzt auch irgendwie noch da sein Ei zu legen, bis das dann irgendwann mal eine zu dieser Verordnung kommen kann und das heißt, es ist jetzt einfach nur gezeigt, so okay Parlament, wo ja alle
ähm Mitgliedsstaaten so ausführlich vertreten sind. So, da gibt's jetzt einen breiten Konsens, aber von dem Ministerrat irgendwie weiterhin.
Kann man vielleicht nochmal kurz sagen, also wie das grundsätzlich im äh auf EU-Ebene funktioniert, ist die Kommission reicht ein Vorschlag äh ein, äh auf den kann dann das äh Parlament eine,
eine eine Meinung zu äh abgeben und das ist jetzt quasi in der das erste Mal passiert,
die man sich wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr lange darüber unterhalten hat und also Abertausende an Veränderungsvorschlägen vor allem eingereicht wurden. Also es ist äh wir hatten ja auch vor einem Jahr hier mit Christen Fiedler auch bei Lokbuch gesprochen und da kam das ja schon ganz gut durch, ja. Das hat ja dann auch,
viel nach sich gezogen, Lobbyplug und ähnliche äh Projekte. All das ist aus äh der Diskussion nur um diesen einen Vorschlag hervorgegangen.
Und äh jetzt müssen sich halt die anderen Entitäten dazu äußern. Und das ist halt nicht nur das Parlament, sondern eben auch der europäische Rat.
Im Wesentlichen die Regierungen äh vertritt und dann geht das dann in die Verhandlung. So und dann kann's auch nochmal eine zweite Lesung äh geben et cetera und am Ende äh wird es vielleicht sowieso auf so einen ähm,
ähm wie nennt man denn nochmal gleich diese Tätigkeit äh das habe ich jetzt gerade nicht ganz. Also so eine Konsensfindung quasi zwischen Parlament,
und europäischem Rat. Und dann,
wenn wir erst das Endergebnis feststellen. Aber so oder so ein äh Erfolg ist insofern erzielt worden, als das hier ein Konsens erzielt werden konnte durch das,
Parlament. Ich weiß nicht, hast du Details auch über was jetzt eigentlich wirklich drinsteht? Äh da müssen wir, glaube ich, wirklich nochmal,
in Brüssel nachfragen, oder?
Ähm da,
Da habe ich keine Details summe, aber ein gutes an also ein gutes gutes Anzeichen, ja? Weil dieser, wie gesagt, dieser Bericht ist ja von dem Jan-Philipp Albrecht von dem äh Berichterstatter, der Grünen Partei. Ähm.
Also er ist nicht der Berichterstatter der grünen Partei, sondern er ist in dem Moment.
Für diesen für diesen.
Diesen Ausschuss, der da quasi führend ist, äh, tätig. Es gibt immer eine Person, die ist der Berichterstatter und das war in diesem Fall er.
Genau und da er dieses Ding formuliert hat, was jetzt da angenommen wurde, würde ich davon ausgehen, dass das jetzt erstmal auf einer sehr datenschutzfreundlichen Linie ist.
Wobei er jetzt als Berichterstatter eben sehr wohl auch in der Pflicht ist, den Konsens des Parlaments und in dem Fall auch der Ausschüsse herzustellen.
Allerdings kenne ich inhaltlich jetzt weiter nichts großartig dazu,
weil insbesondere im im Hinblick auf diesen langen Gesetzgebungsprozess, der da jetzt oder diesen Findungsprozess, der da noch vor uns steht, das wahrscheinlich,
jetzt auch an dieser Stelle erstmal noch müßig ist, da diese tausende von Änderungsanträgen alles irgendwie im Detail auseinanderzunehmen. Ähm,
Insofern habe ich da jetzt tatsächlich noch keine äh noch kein wirkliches
äh Wissen zu. Allerdings, wer jetzt meine und da ist das jetzt meine Vermutung, wenn es da ein, wenn es da jetzt grobe Probleme zu gäbe,
dann wäre das zu mir durchgedrungen. Das wäre jetzt so meine ähm.
Also dann hältst du dann deine Quellen gehabt.
Hätte ich Köln gehabt, ja. Also wenn's so, das wird jetzt auch bei Netzpolitik org äh sehr,
Also sehr fröhlich entgegengenommen diese Nachricht und nur kurz verkündet. Insofern scheint es da im Moment an dieser Stelle keine großartigen Probleme zu geben, aber im weiteren Verlauf werden dann sicherlich wird dann sicherlich noch der,
Ärger insbesondere mit dem äh Ministerrat kommen. Aber was schön ist, jetzt hat man als,
jetzt hat man eben wenigstens diesen, diesen, diese große Entscheidung der vielen abgegebenen Stimmen, wo man jetzt sagen kann, OK, das ist jetzt hier durch ein,
demokratischen Meinungsbildungsprozess gegangen. Das kann man wohl glaube ich an der Stelle wirklich mal sagen, wenn man sich überlegt, wie viele Leute da äh jetzt,
Änderungsvorschläge gemacht haben, dieser sogenannte Lobbyistensturm, von dem ja da viele berichtet haben,
Wir erinnern uns, Kirsten hatte das ja eindrücklich geschildert, wie das jetzt also alle möglichen,
Interessengruppen sich dazu berufen fühlen und so ein ein so ein starke Lobbyismusaktivität eben noch noch nicht unbedingt äh sie erlebt hätte,
Ähm das heißt also dieser, das wurde jetzt wirklich offensichtlich mal diskutiert, ja? Und lange abgewogen,
Und das ist jetzt hoffe, das klingt nach einer ganz, ganz gut abgehangenen Entscheidung, die da jetzt grade mit einer breiten Mehrheit angenommen wurde.
Gut, das werden wir dann vielleicht nochmal, äh wenn wir mal direkt in Brüssel nachfassen und schauen, wie dort äh die allgemeine Stimmungslage ist und vor allem wie die Stimmung dann äh,
zu sein scheint im Europäischen Rat. Ja.
Wir bleiben in Brüssel.
Genau. Da ist dann nicht so gut gelaufen. Das äh hatte sich ja hier vor zwei Wochen auch schon äh angedeutet, beziehungsweise vor drei Wochen, als ich mit Thomas Luninger gesprochen habe
da sollte ja diese Abstimmung über die Netzneutralität im ITAE Ausschuss bereits äh stattgefunden haben. Das wurde dann kurzfristig nochmal vereitelt durch so einen kleinen äh ja legalen Schlenker, den die Grünen da eingelegt haben.
Bei den bei den Piraten nannte man das, glaube ich, äh Geo-Tricks, oder?
Genau.
Oder? Ich weiß nicht, ich habe da nie so richtig.
Na ja, es war es wurde halt einfach mal auf eine Formalie äh äh bestanden, auf die man vielleicht sonst nicht immer so besteht, nämlich dass alle Änderungsvorschläge in allen Sprachen vorliegen.
Und vorher wurde ja über, was war das nochmal klar? Äh Kunststoff-Tragetaschen, also äh,
Der Volksmund sagt, Plastiktüte äh abgestimmt oder sollte abgestimmt werden. Und da wurde eben dann schon so äh die Schote gerissen mit na ja, aber hier in äh
keine Ahnung, welche Sprache da gefehlt hat, ja, also diese Änderung wurde nicht in Finish ausgedruckt und deswegen ist das alles gegen die Statuten. Und dann äh lag aber eben der entsprechende äh Änderungskatalog auch nicht in allen Sprachen vor,
für eben diese Netzneutralitätsabstimmung und dann wurde das eben dann auch vertagt. Äh nun wurde nicht mehr vertagt, sondern jetzt wurde eben abgestimmt, aber das scheint nicht ganz so viele Freunde gefunden zu haben.
Ja, über den, es wurde abgestimmt in dem ITRI, äh, über den Kompromissvorschlag, der konservativen Berichterstatterin
also das ist jetzt quasi für diese Netzneutralitätsverordnung, hat diese Person die Rolle, die der Jan-Philipp Albrecht hat, für die ähm,
für die Datenschutzverordnung und,
was die Kritik daran ist jetzt, Thomas hatte das ja in in der Sendung ausführlich auch dargestellt, dass es äh diese die Definition von Specialist Services darin gibt. Und zwar ähm.
Dürfen jetzt nach diesem Kompromissvorschlag die äh Zugangsanbieter ähm mit den den Nutzern,
Spezialdienste anbieten und mit diesen vereinbaren. Äh die einzige Einschränkung, die jetzt da ist und das ist natürlich wieder so eine Papiereinschränkung ist, dass sie das nur bei ausreichender Kapazität,
und ohne Beeinträchtigung des Internetzugangs tun dürfen. Nun das ist natürlich äh beeint ohne Beeinträchtigung des Internetzugangs ähm,
Ist natürlich eine ähm eine Einschränkung, die sehr dehnbar ist,
und bei ausreichender Kapazität ist äh verständlich, denn ein Angebot, für das ich keine Kapazität habe, sollte ich nicht anbieten. Das heißt,
die Einschränkungen sind da eben sehr äh sehr weich und ähm,
es scheint jetzt da im Moment sieht es so aus und das ist eben der federführende Ausschuss ähm,
dass wir diese Specialist Services ähm bekommen werden. Das ist genau das, was ich wie immer sage, wo man sagt, okay, ja klar, Netzneutralität, auf jeden Fall, für alles, was Internet ist und für alles, was eben nicht Internet ist,
ähm machen wir äh wieder schön wilden Westen mit äh der stärkere gewinnt.
Und jetzt ist aber nicht so klar definiert, was das eine und was das andere ist und deswegen kann es alles Mögliche sein.
Genau. Also gewünschens wünschenswert wäre eben gewesen, äh diese Definitionsspielräume eben nicht zu lassen, sondern und Specialized Services explizit eben auszuschließen.
Jetzt gilt natürlich auch hier also auch hier ist das, glaube ich, erste Lesung, das heißt, das ist jetzt noch kein umgesetztes Gesetz.
Nee, das ist noch nicht mal erste Lesung, das ist jetzt noch nur der ähm der die Abstimmung in federführenden Ausschuss und jetzt.
Ach so, ja okay, aber die Abstimmung im federführenden Ausschuss muss man sagen, ist relativ Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das eben dann vom Parlament auch mehrheitlich so mitbeschlossen wird.
Genau wichtig. Und das ist die die äh richtig und wichtig. Die ähm im Parlament jetzt in zwei Wochen dann auf dem Tisch liegen und,
In der Regel orientieren sich ja die Abgeordneten dann an einem federführenden Ausschuss und sagen, ja, das sind äh weise Menschen, die haben da lange drüber gesprochen. Mein ähm,
Mein Partei,
genosse Mitglied, Kamerad kommt zurück und sagt, das hat schon alles grob seine Richtigkeit, da können wir nicht mehr rausschlagen, also,
machen wir es so. Es sei denn.
Es gibt einen Shitstorm.
Es gibt ein ein Faxstorm und äh E-Mail-Storm. Das sind genau die Sachen, auf die der,
Thomas hingewiesen hatte schon in der Sendung ich gestern Abend auch noch ein paar Faxe geschickt. Das ist echt ganz lustig. Also es fehlt so dieses dieses Geräusch oder so, ne? Also äh man weiß halt immer nicht so krass, äh ist das Fax.
Ja.
Ja ich komme hier so ein bisschen vor bei diesem Fax klicken, wie irgendwie so jemand beim Senden seiner ersten E-Mail, ne, wenn man so auf Senden drückt, dann weg. Ja, und das dann so, wie ist die jetzt wirklich geschickt so,
genau, es ist echt aber ich ich hoffe mal, dass da jetzt irgendwie bei denen äh Faxe aufm Tisch liegen,
Interessant ist äh also jetzt ist genau der der Moment und die letzte Gelegenheit äh bei den,
ähm bei den Abgeordneten für die Netznetralität zu werben und jetzt sollte man dieses save the Internet dot EU Angebot nutzen, welches eben wirklich nichts kostet,
eure Zeit und man kann da schön ein paar Faxe klicken.
Drücken sie jetzt auf Stopp und äh surfen sie diese Webseite ihres Vertrauens an und füllen sie alles auf.
Und wie gesagt, also Thomas hat das alles schon erklärt, deswegen,
Interessant will ich aber noch sagen, was ja also.
Ist das die Fax Melodie? Nein.
Ich wollte nur so ein bisschen,
Möglichkeit geben dazu.
Ah genau, wir machen jetzt kurz Pause,
Okay und aber was Thomas auch schon genannt hatte, die Roaming äh Gebühren sollen ja dafür fallen,
Ja, also kein Roaming mehr. Jetzt ist natürlich die also das finde ich ja einen interessanten diese Abwägung finde ich ja sehr interessant, was da wieder gehandelt wird, ne? Dass man sagt, ja,
Ähm also ich frage mich halt, wo,
Also da offenbar die Netzanbieter nicht Sturm dagegen laufen,
Kann man sich vorstellen, wie viel Gewinn die sich von diesen Netzneutralitätsverletzungen versprechen.
Sogar auf Roaming verzichten.
Genau, sie verzichten auf ihre signifikanten Einnahmen durch das Roaming.
Was ihnen nebenbei auch noch intern die Abrechnung total vereinfacht. Das heißt, da wird auch echt was entschlackt, ne? Also
ist ist eine ist eine blöde, ist eine blöde Sache, so diese diese kreuz- und querabrechnung und da sind, das ist wirklich ein
konvolut aus Verträgen, je nachdem welchen Tarif ich jetzt wieder habe, ne, was wird mir dann berechnet, wenn ich im Ausland bin, dann müssen die ganzen Netzbetreiber untereinander irgendwie ihre Abrechnungen da machen und sich gegenseitig Datenvolumen und so weiter in in Rechnung stellen. Das ist jetzt für keinen besonders schön,
Das heißt, sie profitieren davon. Da wird echt ein bisschen äh Overhead abgebaut, ähm weil sie das jetzt irgendwie einheitlich machen können in der gesamten EU,
EU interne Telefonie für maximal neun Cent äh soll sie gedeckelt werden, das heißt, ich kann dann äh in,
anderen EU-Land anrufen. Das kostet maximal äh neunzehn Zentiminute,
Ähm auf diese ganzen, was ja normalerweise irgendwie, wenn du irgendwie Roaming, wenn du im in der EU unterwegs bist, zahlst du irgendwie fünfundsiebzig äh Cent Grund,
Gebühr pro Transaktion und dann nochmal irgendwie zwanzig Cent drauf oder so. Das heißt, da lassen sie sich eine Menge Gewinn abknapsen,
Um sich den,
Offenbar dann mehrfach wieder zurückzuholen durch diese Netzneutralitätsverletzung. Nur um mal zu zeigen, was die auch für.
Hast du den Erkenntnisse dadrüber? Ich meine, ich höre jetzt immer nur telefonieren und SMS, was ist mit Internet Roaming?
Ähm kann ich jetzt leider keine einhundertprozentig gesicherte Aussage zu treffen. Aber.
Das müssen wir noch mal hinterher forschen.
Ich habe da was gelesen, das ist eben auch günstiger. Also es wird auch gedeckelt. Du hast nicht EU.
Ist nicht der Punkt. Kann nur genauso oder ja, also auch da müsste eigentlich das.
Da müssten wir nochmal schauen. Da bin ich, also ich habe da was zu gelesen, ich hab's mir aber nicht nicht äh genau notiert, deswegen kann ich da keine genaue Aussage zu treffen.
Aber der Punkt, den ich machen wollte, ist so, das ist Roming ist das, wo du gerade im Moment noch richtig gut dran gemelken kannst, als als äh als Telefon äh Mobiltelefonanbieter.
Also, wir gehen mal davon aus,
dass es jetzt nicht nur möglich ist, solche Dienste zu machen, sondern weil einfach die andere Kuh geschlachtet wurde, äh werden sich jetzt alle auf diesen neuen Weidebetrieb äh stürzen und dann wird's wahrscheinlich ein bisschen eklig.
Bis die Kuh wund ist.
Die Wunde Kuh. Ja, gehen wir zurück nach Deutschland.
Ja, in Deutschland tut sich was.
Wirklich? Ja, aber hör mal. Och.
Ja, aber hör mal, jetzt wird hier die die absolute Hand,
äh der der demokratischen Prozesse wird jetzt hier äh zur Faust geballt. Und zwar wird es jetzt ein NSA Untersuchungsausschuss geben,
Weil ja, du erinnerst dich letztes Jahr im Sommer.
Du war doch was.
Da war ja was. Das ist echt sehr schön. Also noch in dieser Woche soll der eingesetzt werden,
und bereits im April mit der Arbeit beginnen. Ich weiß nicht genau, wann der quasi Edward Snowdens äh Enthüllung in das Licht der Welt erblickten. Ich glaube, das war das nicht sogar äh.
Das war so.
Ja, also ein Jahr später kann man dann schon mal echt ein Untersuchungsausschuss und Untersuchungsausschuss, ich meine, frag mal Martin Delius, wie lange ein Untersuchungsausschuss geht, ne? Aber okay, wir haben jetzt für mal einen,
Und der soll prüfen, das ist ganz interessant. Ähm er hat drei Themenkomplexe,
Und da da sieht man auch, wie wie die äh wie die Bundesregierung jetzt beabsichtigt dieses diese Angelegenheit zu behandeln. Nämlich, sie möchte prüfen, ob äh Telekommunikationsdaten,
in oder auf dem Weg nach und aus Deutschland heraus abgegriffen wurden und ob deutsche Behörden etwas davon wussten, okay,
Interessant, so den zweiten Teil der Frage, der wird sicherlich weniger äh detailliert behandelt werden. Ähm,
dann zweite zentrale Frage, man kommt da nicht drüber weg. Zentrale Frage, ob Regierungsvertreter oder andere Verfassungsorgane davon betroffen waren?
Das das ist ja immer noch diese diese Dreiteil, also diese diese Trennung, ne, dass man irgendwie so ja, die hören alles ab. Wie auch Angela Merkel, nein. Ja? Ähm und dann drittens.
Ja, ist erstaunlich, ja. Also, nicht nur nicht nur Menschen, sondern auch Führungspolitiker.
Ja, genau, ja.
Und dann drittens äh soll dieser Untersuchungsausschuss Konsequenzen für den besseren Schutz der Privatsphäre ähm
der dem besseren Schutz privater Kommunikation
erarbeiten und vorschlagen. Das heißt, da haben wir dann natürlich wieder diesen Wirtschaftsteil drin, da wird dann sicherlich noch ein bisschen äh D-Mail äh Förderung
rausspringen, dass man da nochmal in dem Bericht dann schreiben kann, ja, wir müssen auf jeden Fall hier, ne? Deutsche Anbieter oder EU-Anbieter und äh alles schön in in der Hand des Staates, damit er hier aufpassen kann und so. Das heißt, da haben wir dann die Wirtschaftsförderung,
auf jeden Fall noch mal drin.
Ist dieses bin, ey. Hatten wir eigentlich schon dieses äh äh Leute sind ja gar nicht interessiert an Sicherheit, weil sonst würden sie ja alle D-Mail verwenden Argument, ist das schon irgendwie auf dem Tisch gelandet?
Kommt noch. Ach so, D-Melk, ja, ich ich halte ja D-Mail hier aus diesem Podcast immer so ein bisschen raus, weil äh ich kriege da immer relativ viel dann über Twitter oder App dot net Hinweise. Das jetzt, also dem her ist GMX ist jetzt soweit, dass sie.
Kostenlos anbieten, ne?
Bieten sie jetzt kostenlos an. Also sie das Ding, das das dieses Schiff sinkt, also so dermaßen rapide, dass die da echt die Ratten mit kostenlos Angeboten noch an Bord halten wollen, ne.
Aber okay, zu viel nicht zu früh freuen. Wie gesagt, ähm der Gesetzesrahmen dafür steht. Ähm.
Mal schauen, was der Untersuchungsausschuss jetzt äh alles noch so herausfinden wird.
Vorsitzender dieses äh NSA Untersuchungsausschusses, das finde ich sehr interessant.
Wird der auch so heißen? Ehrlich. Oder wird den du so genannt?
Das weiß ich nicht genau. Der vor den Vorsitz hält Clemens Billinger,
und der ist bereits Vorsitzender des Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums. Und wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, dass
Dieser Ausschuss unter anderem prüfen soll, inwieweit Bundesbehörden seit,
Jahresbeginn zweitausendeins von der US-Spionagetätigkeit wussten
Gleichzeitig aber der Vorsitzende des Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums ist, dann könnte man sagen, das ist echt ein guter Mann, der ist in einer guten Position, denn er hat diese Kontrollgremiums, dieses Kontrollgremiums,
Wissen und kann damit dann eventuell das, ne,
steuern, er darf ja nicht diese Geheimnisse ihm da anvertraut wurden, rausnehmen. Man könnte aber auch sagen, der Typ ist halt äh,
befangen, ja? Also.
Weil er Teil dieses Systems war.
Er ist halt komplett äh ähm ich weiß nicht, ob es zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon war. Er ist aber er hat einen kompletten Interessenkonflikt und,
Ich glaube nicht, dass das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium jetzt in Zukunft noch irgendwie eine annähernd äh,
ernst zu nehmende Information erhält,
sei äh also sofern es die jemals bekommen hat, ne, also Mitglieder wie Christian Ströbele oder ähm Wolfgang äh Neskovic sagen ja, das ist ja absolut absolutes Sockenpuppentheater ist und sich da absolut verarscht vorkommen,
und der Typ, der dem Ding vorsitzt, äh macht jetzt eben auch den den Untersuchungsausschuss. Wir werden sehen, was dabei rauskommt.
Ja, aber ich meine, äh gehört ja auch einer vertrauenswürdigen Organisation an.
Ja, der Christdemokratischen Union. Und es tut sich noch was in Deutschland. Es gab einen, es gab einen,
Ein ein sowas von amüsantes Interview mit Harald Range in der Tageszeitung, hat's.
Das ist der Generalbundesanwalt. Der dann sagte, ja,
Nee, nee, keine Sorge, das wird jetzt keine unendliche Prüfung, ob hier ein Anfangsverdacht vorliegt,
und hier wird auch nichts künstlich herausgezögert, sagt er, der weiß ja immer, also er hat angekündigt in der TAZ, dass er noch in diesem Jahr,
zweitausendvierzehn noch in diesem Jahr wird der Generalbundesanwalt feststellen, ob ein Anfangsverdacht,
für Spionagetätigkeit besteht.
Na ja, ich meine, haben sie in der Rekordzeit von nur achtzehn Monaten irgendwie.
Noch in diesem Jahr wird ja das.
Vielleicht finden sie auch heraus, man muss das auch ernst nehmen, das ist ja ein ein demokratisch gewählter Organisationsform hier auch, nicht wahr, ist ja auch Teil unserer Demokratie. Vielleicht stellen sie auch fest, dass kein Anfangsverdacht vorliegt.
Steht. Ja, genau.
Dann ist er auch gut.
Das fand ich aber sehr schön, was er in diesem Interview auch nochmal äh erklärte, ist, dass er erst dann, wenn dieser Anfangsverdacht, wenn über diesen Anfangsverdacht beschrieben wurde
dann kann er sagen, ob er eventuell nicht ermittelt, weil er Schaden von der von Nation und Vaterland ab
äh abhalten will, wegen dieser äh Klausel, wo er eben dann sagen kann, okay, wenn eine Ermittlung in dieser Strafsache äh zu,
große außenpolitische Schwierigkeiten für die Bundesrepublik ähm,
provozieren könnte, dann können wir das, dann können wir es trotzdem im Sack verschwinden lassen. So. Das hatten wir ja hier auch schon mehrfach besprochen. Im weiteren Verlauf des Interviews fordert er dann äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Quellen-TKÜ. Also das ist ein,
Du kannst dir das nicht ähm,
Also quellen TKÜ, ne, Staatstrojaner. Man kann sich das und denen kündigt er übrigens auch für Ende des Jahres an, da das BKA ja, wie wir bereits wissen, mit der Firma Gamma,
da jetzt äh in den in den Planungen steht, wie man denn etwas machen könnte, dass man irgendwie halbwegs gegenüber der,
den Wahrern der Verfassung äh verteidigen könnte und an ihm vorbeischmuggeln könnte.
Tja, ciao.
Also dieses Interview muss man echt mal lesen. Ich hab's gestern mir noch mal angeschaut, ich konnte das nicht an einem Stück lesen. Also es ist das ist wirklich eine sehr äh symptomatisch
was er da äußert. Ich habe auch Kritik gehört, dass die
dass die TAZ äh da viel zu freundlich fragt und ihm irgendwie seinen ganzen Bullshit ähm unwidersprochen lässt. Ähm ich persönlich fand das äh beim Lesen, also
es es zeigt wirklich, wie wie absolut twistet das ist so.
Potentiell schmerzhaft.
Ja, also man muss wirklich die Sätze sind an für sicher immer alle sehr schön, aber wenn man die mal so in Zusammenhang setzt und den größeren Zusammenhang,
das jetzt so dieses Geschehen da betrifft, ne? Also so die USA äh forschen hier äh Leute aus und und er weiß zwar nicht mal, ob ein Anfangsverdacht besteht, weiß aber, dass wir auf jeden Fall eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Staatstrojaner brauchen.
Das ist schon.
Naja, hat sich da ja eigentlich letztes Jahr schon ganz gut festgelegt, dass er da Anfangsverdacht nicht sieht, nicht, also von daher, warum sollte er seine Meinung groß ändern.
Er prüft das noch, er prüft das noch. Hat er, hat er gesagt, hat man uns versprochen,
Okay, also das ist das ist das, das wird da, da wird's noch einiges amüsantes geben, wenn wir nicht andere Themen finden, die die zu den Zeitpunkten dann noch wichtiger sind, aber da kann man äh da wird man, glaube ich, sich jetzt noch noch viel Schmerz äh
zufügen können, indem man diesen Untersuchungsausschuss verfolgt und den Harald Range bei seiner Entscheidungsfindung, ob ein Verdacht besteht.
Ja
kommen wir zu den USA. Da ist die Debatte ja auch noch nicht so ganz äh beendet. Und es gibt äh weiß nicht, also wo die Internetszene ist Not in könnte man sagen.
Es gab äh genau Mark Zuckerberg, der äh Facebook-Gründer ähm und glaube ich immer noch Eigner, ne? Also ähm.
Inbegriff der Schützer der Privatsphäre.
Genau der hat sich also der Typ, ne, der ist ja echt äh,
Ich weiß nicht, also ich habe äh ich habe diesen Film gesehen, der Social Network da ähm wo er jetzt ja schon nicht so das beste Bild seines Charakters äh gezeichnet wurde. Er hat dann,
Habe ich irgendwie gesehen, seine früher hat er eine Visitenkarte, auf der einfach nur drin steht IMCEO Bitch,
Also ich bin hier der Chef Nutte so ungefähr. Äh das war also seine Vorstellung seiner Rolle in diesem Konzern. Ähm den er da gegründet hat,
Ich finde den, ich weiß nicht, was ich von dem halten soll, aber vielleicht ist es auch egal, was man jetzt persönlich.
Ich kenne ihn nicht persönlich, von daher habe ich keine persönliche Meinung über ihn. Ich kann mir meine Meinung auch nur aus dem äh bilden, was er,
macht und tut, aber interessanterweise und ich würde jetzt das gar nicht so sehr auf ihn beziehen, sondern mehr auf so diese ganze Industrie, in der sie äh sich eben mit Facebook,
befindet und da ist er ja auch nicht alleine. Äh Silicon Valley äh an sich quasi sieht diese ganze Überwachungs-Affäre natürlich äh sehr kritisch,
Das heißt natürlich, also man hätte auch sagen können, vielleicht sehen sie es gar nicht so kritisch, aber sie sehen's kritisch, schlicht und ergreifend, weil sie natürlich ihre Fälle davon schwimmen sehen in Form von Vertrauen,
die User eben nicht mehr bereit sind, in ihre Dienste zu investieren, weil sie da nämlich
werden und äh mitgespeichert et cetera und äh wäre, sagen wir mal die Frage nach Auswertung durch die Unternehmen selber und wie man da äh selbst ähm vielleicht,
analysiert und verkauft wird, äh nicht schon schlimm genug, kommt halt jetzt noch diese Sache dazu,
Und offensichtlich war er ein bisschen äh wütend und hat dann irgendwie Obama äh angerufen. Die Möglichkeit äh hat er wohl. Er hat ja auch schon mal mit ihm diniert,
einmal öffentlich, sicherlich haben sie sich auch schon mehr als einmal äh gesehen. Ich meine, diese Unternehmen sind für die Entwicklung von Amerika sehr wichtig und äh ja, er kann das halt machen, dann halt den Telefonhörer in die Hand und sagt, ja, Obama-Alter,
so geht's ja nicht.
Die US-Regierung sollte ein Verteidiger des Internets sein und keine Bedrohung
schrieb er in seinem Facebook-Profil. Ich habe mit ich habe Präsident Obama angerufen und meine Frustration darüber zum,
gebracht? Welchen Schaden die Regierung für unser aller Zukunft anrichtet. Leider sieht es so aus, als würde es noch lange dauern, bis zu einer Reform kommt. Ähm.
Spricht doch etwas Pessimismus aus ihm heraus.
Es ging um die in die äh es ging um eine Reaktion darauf, dass die NSA auch neben allen anderen Seiten, die sie nennen, ermittelt oder faked, das wohl auch mal bei Facebook getan hätte,
und ähm auch da in Reaktion darauf, dass die NSA Millionen von Computer rund um die Welt mit äh Schadsoftware infiziert,
und so weiter. Also äh Mark Zuckerberg, derjenige, der unser aller Daten hat,
Regt sich jetzt darüber auf, dass die US-Regierung die sammelt. Ja, also das ist das ist, muss man sich auch mal vor Augen.
Na, ich glaube, das Sammeln ist äh gar nicht so sehr das Problem, was er an der Stelle hat, sondern das ist natürlich das in dem Moment, wo ähm bekannt wird, dass die
US-Regierung, Webseiten aufsetzt, die äh sich als Facebook ausgeben, aber dann letzten Endes äh den Leuten Trojanern auf die Büchse installieren. Dass das natürlich auf seinen oder den Leumont seines Dienstes äh
zurückgeht so. Das ist ja auch absolut nachvollziehbar. Ich meine, das fänden wir ja jetzt auch nicht so spaßig, wenn Lokbuchen jetzt Politik hier so eine Virenschleuder wäre und wir aber überhaupt gar keine auf unserer Webseite haben sollen, die Webseite quasi nur an irgendeiner anderen Stelle zwischendurch vorgegaukelt wird,
Und das kann ich mir schon vorstellen. Ich meine, wenn du so CEO von Facebook wärst und diese Nachricht würde äh aufschlagen, ich meine, da würdest du auch an die Decke gehen, jetzt unabhängig von deiner politischen Disposition.
Dann würde ich sagen.
Genauer. Und ich rufe jetzt hier mal beim Präsident of the United States an und sage, Alter, Lahm, so geht's nicht.
So nicht. Na ja, ähm es gab noch andere Leute, die sich geäußert haben zu zu Edward Snowden. Äh an an der Stelle, das fand.
Bei Angela anrufen und da mal einen dicken Max machen.
Hast du die Nummer? Nein.
Der äh Bill Gates,
äußerte dann dem äh gegenüber dem Rolling Stone. Ja.
Ich bin langweilig und scheiße.
Sagt,
ja die Regierung kann also abhören. Ähm es muss mal eine eine Diskussion darüber geben. Das sieht ja sowohl auch ein.
Der Staatstrank, der junge Mann.
Aber äh was hat er gesagt? Dann wurde er gefragt, was was er denn jetzt so von Snowden hält und da hat er gesagt, ich denke, er hat das Gesetz gebrochen, also würde ich ihn mit Sicherheit nicht als Helden bezeichnen.
Krass, oder? Ich meine, da hätte man doch echt so Bill Gates bin ich immer ich weiß nicht, ich meine, der Typ ist ja immer noch einer der reichsten Menschen dieser Erde.
Glaube mittlerweile ist er wieder sogar der.
Sogar weder der reichste, ähm,
Ist erstaunlich, also man könnte da ja auch andere Probleme als irgendwie die gesellschaftlichen Probleme, die wir jetzt irgendwie in diesem Netzkram besprechen, mal,
im Vorschlagen, sich zur Brust zu nehmen, ja? Macht er ja teilweise auch mit. Aber okay, also das ist eine sehr komische, sehr komische Äußerung. Da finde ich Steve äh äh Wosniak, den Apple Mitbegründer,
ähm sehr viel sympathischer, der sagte, auf der Cebit äh in Hannover snoden sei ein moderner Held und sollte in die USA zurückkehren dürfen und außerdem sollte man Apple nicht vertrauen.
Außerdem wüsste er nicht, ob man Apple vertrauen kann. Das fand ich äh insgesamt die sympathischere Äußerung an der Stelle.
Was hat er gesagt? Er wüsste er wüsste nicht oder man.
Äh ja.
Noch gar nicht gelesen.
Äh oder er hat gesagt, man müsste ich kann nicht sagen, ob man Apple vertrauen kann, war die wörtliche.
Na okay, mhm. Ja, na gut, dabei hat er wahrscheinlich einfach zu wenig Einblick.
Ja, wahrscheinlich hat er, wurde er einfach nur gefragt und also der, ja, er wurde halt gefragt, ob's eine Hintertür in Apple Software gibt. Okay, da kann er natürlich auch nicht drauf antworten, weil er seit, weiß ich nicht, inzwischen zwei Jahrzehnten nicht mehr oder mit seit einem Jahrzehnt nicht mehr mit der,
Apple Software betraut ist, oder? Was ist sein Status? Ich glaube, er ist noch, er steht.
Software war sowieso noch nie äh er wird seit Ewigkeiten als Mitarbeiter geführt
Also er ist sozusagen nie gekündigt worden, er arbeitet da aber nicht. Das ist eher so ein Modus Operandi, den man da gefunden hat. Äh Software war ja eh nie sein Ding. Er war ja der Hardware-Guye
und ähm also er wird sicherlich auch Software, also.
Der hat auch mal Software geschrieben.
Ja, natürlich äh kann er auch Software schreiben, aber er ist jetzt nicht, sagen wir mal, für die Entwicklung des Betriebssystems und so weiter.
Wesentlichen bekannt. Wie auch immer, er ist auf jeden Fall ein interessanter äh Freigeist und äh hat da natürlich auch eine ganz andere Position. Und ähm,
dass die sich von Bill Gates unterscheidet, na ja, das wundert mich jetzt auch nicht sonderlich, muss ich sagen. Ist halt einfach ein Langweiler,
noch nie was anderes.
Ich ich dachte, der wäre cool, als als es diese äh als es diese Seidenfeld und Gate Spots gab, das halte ich nach wie vor für eine der großartigsten
Produkte eines für einige der großartigsten Produkte die die Werbeindustrie jemals hervorgebracht hat.
Ja, deswegen sind sie auch nach zwei Spots abgesetzt worden, weil sie äh den Mut verloren haben.
Sogar drei.
Ist, ich glaube ein zwei sind gesendet worden, ein Dritter wurde produziert aber schon offiziell nicht mehr ausgestrahlt, ich weiß gar nicht, ob der hier liegt. Ich glaube, der ist dann noch geleakt worden, aber.
Also es gab drei lustige Bill Gates Spots.
Aber sie hatten einfach aber sie hatten halt keinen Mumm die Nummer durchzuziehen. Wenn sie das, wenn sie das durchgezogen hätten.
Hätte ich mir ein Windows-Rechner gekauft.
Ja, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das in irgendeiner Form in dem kreativen Fleisch von Herrn Gates entstanden ist.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Es gab es gab drei es, du hast Recht, es gab zwei Seidenfeld Gates äh Spots und einen äh zu seinem Ausscheiden als Mitarbeiter bei Microsoft. Äh.
Nee, das klappt nicht, glaube ich, der Dritte war das nicht der, wo er dann noch mit dem Arsch wackelt und den haben sie dann schon offiziell nicht gesendet? Ist irgendwie so.
Echt, das war das war der mit den Schuhen,
wie dem auch sei. Also die die waren alle cool. Also die waren, okay, super. Bill Gates ist nicht cool, aber er hatte drei lichte Momente seines Lebens, wo ihn irgendjemand in lustige Filme gepackt hat. Mit Selbstironie. Egal.
Ja, ja. Du warst sicherlich nicht auf Seiten des gewachsen ist, also dafür,
oder Garantie nicht, weil sonst hätte er auch genug gehabt, das irgendwie dann auch durch zu äh fechten. So.
Ja, der Typ, ja, okay, aber ist auch eigentlich egal. Also, ich meine.
Das wird nichts mehr mit der Begeisterung äh.
Bill Gates ruft etwas vom Absteggleis herüber, äh wird natürlich.
Ja, vor allem jetzt begibt er sich schon wieder äh in diesen diesen diesen Löwenkäfig äh IT, in dem man eigentlich gar nichts mehr zu melden hat und dabei war er so in diesem i safe the world Ding eigentlich viel besser unterwegs.
Ja ach ja gut Birgits, ne?
So ist es halt. Naja.
Man ohne Einfluss hat nur noch Geld. So, dann kommt die äh das war eine Meldung, da müssen wir mal gucken, wie wir die zusammengekratzt kriegen. Ähm.
Ist viel äh Unklarheit.
Da ist irgendwie Unklarheit, was das jetzt also ich habe da Unkleid, was das wirklich bedeutet. Die Meldung lautet, ähm,
für das Internet gibt es eine Aufgabe, die erfüllt werden muss, nämlich die,
Also eine äh ein Gremium oder eine eine zentrale Stelle, die sagt, diese,
IP-Adresse zum Beispiel, die kriegt diese Person oder die gehört dieser über die verfügt, diese Person beziehungsweise dieser Konzern im Internet.
So und das ist jetzt nicht eure also quasi eure IP-Adresse, die eure Fritzbox oder was zu Hause bekommt, die gehört ja dann eurem Mobilfunkanbieter, beziehungsweise jemanden, der euer Mobilfunk
Anbieter ermöglicht, darüber zu verfügen und es muss an einer Stelle sichergestellt werden, dass jetzt nicht,
jemand andere, jemand anderes auch diese IP-Adresse im Internet benutzt. Ähm,
Und zwar jetzt nicht technisch sichergestellt werden, sondern eben auch zentral irgendwie mal logistisch sichergestellt werden, dass äh es da in den in den öffentlichen Adressbereichen keine Konflikte gibt. Ähm,
Und diese Aufgabe nimmt die,
ICAN war. Die Internet Corporation for Asight Names and nombers. Und diese Aufgabe erfüllt sie im Auftrag der USA, das heißt, die eigentliche Aufgabe äh Internet ist,
wählt die USA in ihrer Hand,
Das heißt, sie koordinieren, sie haben letztendlich die Autorität darüber, wie einmalige Namen und Adressen im Internet vergeben äh werden. Dazu gehört also DNS und IP-Adressen. Und jetzt haben die USA angekündigt, haben gesagt, dieses,
Diese Aufgabe möchten wir statt einem,
einer Firma, die das bei uns im Prinzip macht, äh überführen in einen internationalen Multi-Stake-Holder-Prozess.
Das ist die Meldung. Und es wurde dann irgendwie teilweise gefeiert, ja,
Die USA wollen jetzt die Kontrolle über das Internet abgeben. Und ich bin mir nicht so also ich weiß halt nicht, ob die USA jemals ähm,
Sage ich mal, Macht ausgeübt haben oder Schindluder betrieben haben durch die Tätigkeit der ICAN. Dafür war ich einfach leider in meinem Leben nie mit dieser ICAN äh nennenswert konfrontiert.
Na ja, so ich mein das Konfiszieren von äh Domains und so weiter ist ja durchaus äh hat ja durchaus stattgefunden, ja,
Die USA hat sich ja schon mal auch bestimmter Domains einfach so bemächtigt,
der Meinung war, dass da Schindluder getrieben wurde. Also es ist schon so, dass natürlich die äh Kontrolle, die die äh USA derzeit de facto,
da einfach eine Rolle spielt. Und wenn's nur äh das Verhindern äh der Einflussnahme anderer Länder äh ist, ja, also selbst wenn sie's jetzt nicht selber äh,
brauchen oder gebrauchen, ähm ja, könnte man auch sagen, da ist es vielleicht bei den USA auch noch besser aufgehoben, als jetzt äh woanders, ne? Also auch ob sowas wie die UNO und so weiter da der richtige Ort ist, so etwas anzu,
ähm siedeln, da habe ich so meine Zweifel und wir hatten die Diskussion ja auch schon, dass äh vor einem halben Jahr oder so, weißt du, wo die ganze Diskussion ging mit der ITU zum Beispiel sehr viel mehr,
Verantwortung im Internetkontrollprozess äh gegeben werden und die ITU ist halt letzten Endes nichts anderes als äh äh alle Staaten in Form ihrer nationalen Telekommunikationsunternehmen äh ja
ein Club, den man wirklich nicht.
An irgendwelchen Kontrollzentren äh der Internetinfrastruktur Walden sehen möchte,
Ich glaube, dass sich hier einfach hinter dieser Meldung nicht sehr viel dahinter ist. In gewisser Hinsicht wissen die USA, dass sie ihren Einfluss, ihren unmittelbaren, direkten, verbrieften Einfluss auf,
Internetregelungsautoritäten zurückfahren müssen. Das ist da da herrscht einfach ein grundsätzlicher, nachvollziehbarer politischer Druck, dass es einfach nicht sein kann
den USA quasi so eine nationale Behörde da unmittelbar
Einfluss nimmt. Nun ist natürlich das Netz in den USA entwickelt, geboren worden, et cetera. Also all das, von dem wir heute reden und was wir heute als selbstverständlich ansehen, das muss man ja auch nochmal sehen, hat sich aus einem USA-Forschungs,
gramm des Verteidigungsministeriums entwickelt und all diese ganzen
Organisationen, die heute da hoheitliche Aufgaben übernehmen, sind in irgendeiner Form aus einem militärisch oder universitären Kontext hervorgegangen und hat sich dann schrittweise versucht,
unterschiedlich aufzustellen. Die hat ja auch so diese äh Vergangenheit. Äh es gab ja da tatsächlich mal einen Modus, wo tatsächlich Vertreter der gewählt wurden durch das Volk.
Das Internet folgt. Du erinnerst dich, ja, also unter anderem wurde ja Andy Müller Magun mal äh in den Rat äh gewählt, ja, der ist,
der einzige wirklich äh gewählte Vertreter und äh der hat dann sich hier gegen Jeannette Hoffmann und so weiter in Deutschland äh durchgesetzt. Das war natürlich ein Home Run und hat da tatsächlich dann in dem Iconboard äh eine Zeit lang
quasi die Netznutzer vertreten. Jetzt war das nicht unbedingt so, dass man da jetzt gleich die Revolution hat äh äh
können, nur weil jetzt um die eine einzige Person in diesem Machtspielchen da äh auf einmal hineinindiziert wurde. Aber das gab's. Das wurde dann aber auch aufgrund seines Erfolgs danach auch schnell wieder geändert, ja? Also nicht, dass sie sich vielleicht nochmal so einen Hacker eintreten.
Und äh der gesamte demokratische äh Prozess, der da mal erträumt worden äh ist, der findet eben so in der Form heutzutage nicht mehr statt.
Wohin es jetzt geht, keine Ahnung, Multi Stakeholder, ja, meinetwegen ist es vollkommen klar, dass hier alle Kontinente et cetera
äh äh mitwirken müssen und das ist jetzt nicht nur Sache der USA sein kann, wohin die Politik läuft,
Ich glaube aber auch, dass dieser Ihanabereich, um den es ja hier konkret jetzt gerade geht, auch jetzt nicht unbedingt so der Kritischste ist,
Hier geht's wirklich so meine administrative Tätigkeit, die diesen ganzen Verteilungsprozess äh im Griff behalt, das ist,
oder war, sagen wir mal zuletzt auch noch alles etwas kritischer wegen dieser IPV vier Adressenknappheit,
befinden wir uns halt auch langsam in dieser Transition zu V sechs, wo das Problem so nicht mehr besteht und ähm vielleicht da auch die Politik wieder ein bisschen herausgenommen,
wird. Ich habe jetzt auch Schwierigkeiten, diese Meldungen richtig zu interpretieren,
Ähm ich würde sagen, wir behalten das mal im Hinterkopf, beobachten mal, ob's da neue Entwicklungen gibt und vielleicht haben wir dann auch noch ein bisschen mehr Hintergrundinformationen, dann das Ganze auch,
unterfüttern zu können.
Ja, Clemens, wer da vielleicht nochmal die die richtige Stelle gewesen, aber ich äh bin ich,
ich glaube nicht, dass ich da jetzt irgendwie konkret irgendwas merke, großartig ändern wird für die Internetnutzer, so.
Ja, du hast noch was?
Ja, äh wir machen jetzt Werbung.
Moment, ich habe gar keinen passenden Single parat.
Ja ich finde eigentlich die Musik, die ich da gerne hätte, ist kennst du von diesen äh von den Terrentino Rodriguez Be Movies, ja, dieses also dieses mitm Marschetti und so, ähm wo sie am Anfang,
diese Previews von anderen Filmen machen. Und da ist so eine ganz coole Musik, die könnten wir für Werbung nehmen,
Irgendwie sowas.
Aha.
Mhm.
Ja. Und wofür willst du jetzt Werbung machen? Das habe ich jetzt noch nicht so ganz.
Werbung machen für eine Veranstaltung. Sie findet statt am äh Samstag, den fünften April von elf bis neunzehn Uhr in Berlin. Der Ort wird noch bekannt gegeben,
Ähm.
Samstag.
Das ist ein Samstag. Ähm und zwar ist, handelt es sich um ein Barcamp.
Eine sogenannte Unkonferenz.
Konferenz, eine Unkonferenz in Berlin, die von ein paar äh gut denkenden Personen,
ähm initiiert wurde. Äh das ist also eine, also ein ist eine offene Tagung mit offenen Workshops
deren Inhalte und Ablauf von den Teilnehmenden zu Beginn der Tagung selbst entwickelt und im weiteren Verlauf gestaltet werden. Kann man sich ungefähr so vorstellen, dass man sagt, jetzt ist irgendwie Barcamp, dann kommen Leute nach vorne und schlagen Sessions vor,
Also schlagen Workshops vor. Und diejenigen, die die Workshops vorschlagen, müssen nicht notwendigerweise diejenigen sein, die ähm,
die sie auch halten oder die, die äh zentralen Kompetenzanlauf stellen für diesen Workshop sind. Sondern man kann sich eben auch Workshops wünschen. Und welche dann zustande kommen und welche nicht ergibt sich dann durch die Nachfrage.
Einfach mal was fordern.
Genau. Ja, er gibt sich dann durch die, durch die
Teilnehmer, ja? Also wenn man schlägt eine Session vor und entweder sagen, jetzt sagt eine kritische Menge, jo, das wollen wir auch tun und dann äh dann kommen sie zu dieser Session oder die Session kommt eben nicht zustande und dann äh finden diese ganzen Sessions,
Sessions statt,
und am Ende des äh des treffen dann wieder alle zusammen und äh wollen, dass das kondensierte Wissen aus ihren Sessions ähm,
geben.
Hat auch ein äh Thema und das ist mal kurz gesagt, was ist zu tun gegen die völlige digitale Überwachung, also hier handelt es sich um eine Veranstaltung, die,
Nach Antworten sucht, um sagen wir mal dieser,
Offensichtlichen äh Situationen, der Totalüberwachung äh zu begegnen, ähm an Antworten hat es ja bisher doch sehr gemangelt
das hatten wir ja auch hier ausführlich, glaube ich, mit einem dreißig C drei und so weiter kam das rüber, beziehungsweise ich würde sagen, auch die gesamte Zeit seit äh Snowden auf dieses äh auf die Bühne getreten ist,
hat äh viele Fragezeichen vor allem erstmal erzeugt
und ja, um vielleicht das ein oder andere Mal abzuarbeiten, gibt's diese Veranstaltung, mir ist nicht so ganz klar, ob die jetzt zum wesentlichen Englisch Deutsch sein wird, sie ist auf jeden Fall angekündigt
nicht. In äh Titel und Beschreibung. Ähm von daher nehme ich mal an, wird beides da sein,
Raum finden. Ja, ein Organisatoren äh lesen sich hier einerlei äh allerlei Namen, die wir auch hier schon zu äh Gast hatten. Anne Roth zum Beispiel, Benjamin Bergemann,
Mit dabei.
Julia Kloiber, Lorenz Mazert und Moritz Tremmel stehen auch noch off. Also auf der off, off öffentlichen Seite. Es gibt da noch noch ein, zwei Leute, die auch sonst damit irgendwie noch ein bisschen was zu beitragen werden,
und das, was ich daran sehr spannend finde, warum ich das überhaupt jetzt für so erwähnenswert halte, ist, dass sie äh all diese Personen,
sage ich mal, auch Organ in netzpolitischen Organisationen oder Gruppen irgendwie aktiv sind. Und ähm,
dieses Treffen aber unabhängig von ihrer Organisationalen Bindung. Ähm,
Anberaumt haben. Das ist also so, es soll spezifisch außerhalb dessen stehen und ist also ein Barcamp, soll offen sein und ich denke, dass das gut sein könnte, dass das ein,
fruchtbaren Nährboden bietet für daraus dann entstehende Dinge,
in welcher Form auch immer. Kann man empfehlen, glaube ich. Wird sicherlich, kostet irgendwie fünf Euro für Unkosten vor Ort oder so.
Es gibt noch keinen Ort, muss man noch dazu sagen.
Ja der.
Irgendwo in Berlin sein wird.
In Berlin sein.
Ja
Möchte ich darauf möchte ich empfehlen.
Wo wir äh bei Veranstaltungen gerade sind, gibt's noch irgendwas oder war's das schon.
Es gibt noch etwas und zwar günstigerweise direkt am Folgetag, nämlich am sechsten April, das heißt, da kann man ein wunderschönes äh netzpolitisches Wochenende machen, voller Workshops,
Und zwar äh veranstaltet die äh Berliner Gazette äh eine eine Workshop und Public Talk mit dem Komplizen. Woran wollen wir zusammen arbeiten in dieser,
Welt. Zusammen mit äh Supermarkt, äh Media äh und einigen anderen Gruppen wollen sie eben dann diesen Workshop dort stattfinden lassen.
Supermarkt ist der Ort, der.
Supermarkt ist der Ort, ist eine äh ja Brunnenstraße, oben so eine kleine Galerie ist das, ne. Da haben sie.
Supermarkt.
Genau, da haben sie aber irgendwie ähm so ein paar Leute, also mehr so Speaker schon ähm,
und Moderatoren sich schon irgendwie gestellt. Das heißt, das wird ein bisschen fester, äh vorformuliert sein oder für etwas fester äh ja wie soll man das sagen? Etwas etwas äh etwas äh strukturierter.
Vorstrukturiert, aber da sind auch die ein oder anderen äh Lokbootnetzpolitik äh Gäste.
Echt fair.
Dani Bruder zum Beispiel vom äh C3 S. Sehe ich hier auf den ersten äh Blick, wie man vielleicht auch kennt, ist Detlef Borchers von Halse äh.
Ich glaube, du hast den gleichen Fehler gemacht wie ich gerade und das vom letzten Jahr gegoogelt. Echt? Ah ja, doch, stimmt.
Dann zu kurz, hatten wir hier auch schon mal Julia Kloiber von der Open Ludget Foundation, die du eben schon genannt hast, äh wird dabei sein und wenn ich mich recht erinnere, ist auch Gregor äh hier für die Seabase am Start, also.
Okay, ja, stimmt. Da werden viele sein. Das äh könnte also dann auch nochmal interessant sein, dass man.
Ein lustiges Wochenende rund um die Zukunft. In Berlin, wenn man wieder eine Ausrede braucht nach Berlin zu kommen, das könnte es sein. Genau.
Genau. Fünfter und sechster April kann man sich mal antun.
Ja, Linus. Dann haben wir's eigentlich, oder?
Ja, jetzt muss ich das nur noch verlinken.
Regelmäßig wieder, ja ne, machen wir.
Wir werden uns bemühen und ansonsten haben wir ja jetzt äh einen wirklich gesehen, dass wir sehr gute Alternativmöglichkeiten haben.
Was soll das denn heißen? Sie haben auch keine Freiheit vor dem Feind.
Nein, es war es ginge einfach auch so darum, dass also ich habe das ja auch in den Kommentaren geschrieben, es war ja nicht nur, dass ich weg war, sondern auch, dass ich mal irgendwie Pause machen,
wollte, weil ich die letzte Sendung, bei der ich da war, jetzt äh inhaltlich nicht mehr so gewinnbringend,
empfunden habe und ich hoffe, dass eine kleine kreative Schaftspause das auch dazu führt, dass wir wieder,
mehr unaufgeregt.
Und neutral berichten können. Genau.
Neutral weiß ich nicht, äh unaufgeregt.
Ja, nee, es ist grundsätzlich nicht einfach, äh bei so regelmäßigen Formaten, ne, immer wieder äh über längere Zeitraum, grad so Podcasts und Gespräche macht, da immer wieder denselben Level halten zu können, ist eigentlich gar nicht möglich.
Es ist, ich.
Daher ist so eine Pause immer ganz gut. Ich bräuchte auch mal eine.
Es ist ja, kannst du machen. Das es ist vor allem.
Bin ja sogar dabei, wenn ich nicht dabei bin.
Ich find's vor allem schwierig, dass die dass die ähm,
Also diese Themen sind halt irgendwie ein bisschen anstrengend mitunter, ne? Und das passiert halt teilweise ähm,
viel über das berichtet werden muss, aber es bewegt sich wenig,
so dass das, was man berichtet, äh etwas teilweise gleichförmig äh bleibt. Das ist unter Umständen dann, wenn es sich nur um schlechte Nachrichten handelt über ein gesamtes Jahr, auch mal anstrengend.
Sollten wir vielleicht einfach mal ein bisschen noch unser Portfolio erweitern, noch ein paar Prominews einbauen und so, ja, also da gibt's dann sicherlich genug zu lachen. Genauso wie Spiegel Online das auch macht.
Panorama. Ja, mehr, mehr Piraten, mehr Piratenberichterstattung.
Ja, das wird ja jetzt nix mehr, glaube ich. Was, was willst du da jetzt noch bricht?
Also gibt auf jeden Fall viel zu lachen.
Ja, aber das.
Auf weh, ne? So, dann lachen wir's einem im Hals.
Popcornpiraten DE ist ja schon eingestellt. Da brauchen wir.
Ja, nicht auf das Niveau will ich mich auch nicht begeben.
Nicht mehr nachzulegen. Gut, das lassen wir jetzt mal dabei. Wir sagen tschüss.
Tschüss. Ciao ciao.